[Music]
[Applause]
contestant number four
verity price
a great read
a great read beardy price
when i was a little girl i used to love
snuggling on my dad's lap while he read
me fairy tales
not surprisingly
i grew up wanting the fairy tale
to be happily married with beautiful
kids a gorgeous home and a great career
by 13.
i never dreamed i would turn 40
unmarried no children and living
in my sister and brother-in-law's spare
room
for my ego
this
was a scary tale
so i hid
in the spare room
eating ice cream
and binge watching
netflix
ponte's chair
have you ever noticed that at your worst
you always run into someone at their
best i had dragged myself to the shops
just to get more ice cream thinking no
one i know
is going to be there
but there
she was
that friend
you know the one
their life is perfect
and they tell you
here i am hand on fridge stuck having to
hear how happily ever after she has
ended up
are you married
with kids
and your own business
and you bought a house
me
great i wanted
to die
i was a mess
my life was a mess
the spare room
was a mess
but this was the mess
where i found
the last letter my dad
ever wrote me
seeing his
familiar handwriting just flooded me
with grief
verity
your life is a book
and if you're not enjoying the read
write a different story
and then watch for a miracle
because i'm watching too
i shot a miracle's dad and
how
how do i write a different story about
this
read my point i went to facebook
and you guessed it
there were no stories of miserable 40
year olds living in spare rooms
but
the letter just lay there
it was like it was looking at me
almost whispering
write a different story
if anyone could write a different story
it was my dad
he wasn't a glass half full guy he was a
anti-lucky i've got a glass guy
when dad was 60
he lost his job
we lost our home
and we had to live
in a camper van
but the story dad told was
we get to live like we're on holiday
he never complained that he'd gone from
a corner office
to selling insurance
door to door
instead
the story he told was
i'm working on my sales skills
and the miracle that happened
dad was salesman of the year and he
bought us a new home
and even
in our last phone call
on his way to hospital
do you know what he said to me
don't worry v
you know i love breakfast in bed
stream
hit me like a bus
my whole life
dad had been showing me how to write a
different story
oh
i picked up my pen
i looked at that friend and i thought
is going to be my best chapter
i looked at the spare room and thought
this is my safe place to start over
i looked
at my love life
and you know what i thought
i have got to stop kissing frogs
when i wrote a different story
my life began to change
i went from feeling shameful
to feeling grateful
and for the first time i stopped
worrying about where i wasn't
and i started enjoying
where i was
and the miracle that happened
within six months i've moved into a new
cottage
much to my sister's relief
within a year i'd kissed
a prince
much to my relief
at 44
i had a baby boy
matched to my doctor's
disbelief
this letter
catapulted me into discovering that it
doesn't matter who you are where you are
what chapter of your life you're in
something as simple as choosing to write
a different story
can make difficult circumstances
a lot easier to deal with
now i think you'll agree with me when i
say the last two years have been a rough
read for us all
but
we've also written different stories
ones where neighbors get to serenade
each other and businesses get to pivot
and innovate
and my all-time favorite was that time
when we all waved our ones and bippity
boppity
your room turned into an auditorium and
mine
an international
stage
my fellow storytellers do you know what
i've learned
fairy tales are great to read to my son
real life is full of detours delays
things that go wrong
but
your life is a book
then every day you get to decide
is your story being written for you
or by you
when my dad reminded me that i was the
author of my life
my life changed
so if you're looking for a change
you want a new chapter or you just fancy
a miracle
pick up your pen and write a different
story
wrap me
it's gonna make for a great read
contest chair
you